[Musique]
alors le paillasson de pommes de terre
pour c'est une recette très simple pour
cette recette etc et pour quatre
personnes
qu'est ce qu'il nous faut eh bien il
nous faut 800 g de pommes de terre ce
sont des bf 15
après les belles française quinzaine en
parlera tout à l'heure il nous faut deux
belles cuillère à soupe de beurre
il nous faut une belle cuillère à soupe
de crème fraîche
il nous faut une cuillère à café de sel
du poivre à votre goût vous savez que
j'aime beaucoup le pas j'en ai pas mal
il nous faut une toute petite pincée de
noix de muscade du persil de la
ciboulette qui sont hachées devant vous
et puis le jus d'un citron
alors on va tout de suite commencer
cette recette alors pour cette recette
ces quatre pommes de terre qu'est ce
qu'on va faire on va les peler alors il
veut les pommes de terre
je vais commencer on peut les u c'est
pas difficile on a un appareil
spécialement pour ça qu'ils s'appellent
peine économe et on va mettre ses pommes
de terre dans l'eau une seconde pour
qu'elles ne noircissent le temps alors
mes quatre tomes de terrasson peu les
voyelles sont dans le bol rempli d'eau
je vais reprendre il devait apposer sur
un torchon propre de façon à les subir
je me répète que ces quatre pommes de
terre pèse 800 grammes au total
et puis la pomme de terre ne faites pas
comme moi la première fois j'ai voulu le
faire sont hors champ
j'ai failli y laisser la main alors oui
je vais à fait les pommes de terre sur
le gros côté d'une frappe au dessus d'un
saladier
alors voilà ça y est donc à propos de
terre son rap et voyez j'ai touché un
peu quand même pas difficile à faire je
vais y rajouter une cuillère à café de
sel mais parfois un petit peu injuste
rase comme ça on va y rajoute également
5 6 tours de moulin à poivre d'entre
vous se fractionne moi j'en ai pas mal
et celui de rap et de muscade et avec
une petite menotte bien mort
vous allez mélanger du sens beaucoup
plus facile à faire avec
n'importe quel instrument et on ne
risque strictement rien tout de suite
après la poêle sur le et là dans cette
fois on va mettre vraiment deux belle
cuillère à soupe de beurre et vous allez
voir pourquoi parce que le truc de la
crème de pommes de terre de paillasson
de pommes de terre
et là il est dans le fait que quand le
maire ont pas être fondue on va y
ajouter toutes nos pommes de terre
râpées et on va les mélanger bien avec
le beurre fondu
qu'est ce qui va se passer chaque
morceau de pomme de terre on va bien
être imprégné du peur et quand on va
étaler la crème et la circuit couverte
avec un beau coup faible et bien tout
sera moelle et vous obtiendrez un
fantastique gâteau de pommes de terre
regardez aussitôt que le beurre fondu on
va y ajouter un commentaire
il ya là le fait parfois rhin je leur ai
juste dit ça c'est très important que le
feu soit il faut qu'il y ait environ 1
cm de hauteur de gaz là vous ajoutez
tout volontaire de foot je vous ferai
remarquer que nous n'avons pas lavé ses
pommes de terre une fois plaisant le
théâtre parce que l'amidon est très
important pour que la peau notaires se
lier regarder ce que je fais doucement
ce genou mésanges de telle façon à ce
que chaque morceau commentaires soient
encore une fois bien imprégné receveur
et puis avec les deux fourchettes
je vais aplatir sur le thème comme une
bête comme une belle galette
voilà en faisons bien revenir sur les
bords vous faites ça une passante égal
puisque sinon on peut noter un seul but
8 à certains endroits qu'à d'autres
hélas en fait comme moi que j'ai trouvé
dans la cuisine couverte qui peut juste
recouvrir la poêle c'est pas du tout le
gouverneur mois le loyer d'un couvercle
de cocottes je le pose dessus et pour 15
minutes à feu doux
on va oublier ses pommes de terre quand
on va les retourner vous allez leur
talent heures elles vont être doré super
un vrai gâteau
en 15 minutes justice aille alors qu'est
ce qui s'est passé pendant ces quinze
minutes une fois je dis bien une fois
une sage et soulever le couvercle au
bout de cinq minutes et les avec une
spatule décrocher les pommes de terre
aux pompiers et maintenant qu'est-ce
qu'il va falloir faire et bien il faudra
la retourner c'était très dur alors là
je vous demande s'il vous plaît
un instant de silence ce que je vais
faire c'est pour la première émission
ici et ma réputation devant vous sentez
jamais fait aucune télévision du monde
n'a osé le réaliser en direct ou presque
retourné sans fil et une crêpe de pommes
de terre devant vous tous je demande un
instant de silence si l'on fait
[Musique]
mais cela cela dit j'ai pas vraiment des
spurs à la maison c'est pas faux si un
truc pour retourner une crêpe dans une
poêle vous glissez d'abord voyez votre
crêpe dans une assiette vous prenez
votre assiette par dessous comme ça vous
posez la loi dessus et vous retrouverez
tout simplement tout vêtement est votre
secret parfaitement dans la poêle à il
faut rajouter voyez un tout petit peu de
beurre et on va soulever légèrement la
crème briller pour faire pénétrer sans
heurt dessous qu'est-ce qu'ils font peur
dix minutes encore de cuisson recouvrir
la poêle et pendant ce temps là on va
essayer en cinq minutes
et au bout de cinq minutes on va
commencer la sauce pourquoi la sauce et
bien parce que la pomme de terre vous
savez est un aliment comme les caisses
qui lui manqueront pas grand chose le
galsi
alors comment faire un repas complet du
soir par exemple avec une crème des
pommes de terre une belle salade est
bien important le calcium est une petite
source une petite sauce à la crème
fraîche au citron aux herbes
c'est à dire au persil et à la
ciboulette c'est pas mal quand ça sera
la peña c'est bon ça fait cinq minutes
qu'ont à retourner la crêpe et dans la
poêle on va commencer la source puisque
il faut que cette souche soit servie
avec la crème bouillante 1 alors nous
avons ici une petite poêle sur feu moyen
on y met une belle cuillère à soupe de
pair voilà summer va prendre tout de
suite on va pendant ce temps coupez un
siphon de presser le jus
ajouter le jus d'un demi-citron cerises
lamrac étudiants
ajouté deux passes et le sel voilà du
poids vous n'hésitez pas et puis on va
ramener la paix dans un 2 voilà une
belle poitrine pour capelle cela c'est
une belle cuillère à soupe de crème
fraîche
on va laisser fondre pendant ce temps là
la crête témoin la poussière mais laval
a glissé sur le plat de service
on s'arrête
délicieux regardez ici notre sol
on a manqué un tout petit peu le feu est
aussitôt qu'il n'y ait pas appel à la
crème fraîche ça peut vous dire ça
montrait rien voilà voilà
on va y ajouter une belle cuillère à
soupe de ciboulette hachée une belle
cuillère à soupe de persil haché
mélanger les torchons la verse dans la
saucière petites secondes s'il vous
plaît l'ac amiens on verra cet essor
dans la social d'ici 15 jours
et puis on va couper leur coût est une
invention de crédit pour un seul homme
est ce qu'elle est qu on va la laisser
dans l'assiette et croyez-moi ce soit
tout simplement dimanche ce soit une
belle salade verte
une belle claque de pommes de terre
comme ça avec un tout petit peu de
sources un peu pointu avec ses herbes
doris léger goût de citron ça une fois
votre histoire très gérable pour le
dimanche sans équivalent
[Musique]